[Music]
all right her HUD 2018 s battlefield
game will be set in World War two
because it sounds like that one might be
paying out
i'mjust McDonald and let's talk rumors
earlier this year EA announced that a
new battlefield is coming but that's the
short and long of what we got out of
them games beat is reporting that the
anticipated title is called battlefield
5 as in the Roman numeral 5 and will be
set during world war ii there are port
sites sources who are quote familiar
with EA's plans the report also suggests
that battlefield 5 was once internally
known as battlefield 2 before changing
names if all these numbers are confusing
you I'll just clear up that this game
won't be a remaster of battlefield 2
which came out in 2005 but is in fact
the all new battlefield 5 reportedly
previously known as battlefield 2 which
will come out in 2018 who's on first the
report added that EA will announce the
game soon and that EA and dice decided
several years ago to move away from
futuristic and modern shooter settings
for battlefield games the news comes as
slightly sad news for Battlefield Bad
Company fans as it was rumored that dice
was working on a third entry in the
series set in the Vietnam War
the report says however that this is not
the case this one will surely be
developing so keep it tuned to games but
[Music]